hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
today marks 19 years since the september
11th terror attacks
frank stiller chairman and ceo of the
tunnel to towers foundation
opens up about losing his brother a
firefighter on 9 11.
he also discusses what this year's
ceremony will look like amid the
coronavirus pandemic
and what he wants younger generations to
know
in october will mark one year since the
world's most wanted terrorist isis
leader abu bakr al-baghdadi was killed
during a u.s raid in syria so are
americans safer today than we were
four years ago former cia station chief
and fox news contributor dan hoffman
weighs in
discussing america's national security
and how the nation
continues to fight terrorism plus
commentary by guy benson
host of the guy benson show the fox news
rundown is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important
to you you can subscribe on your
favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm
harris faulkner i'm greg gutfeld i'm
janis dean
and this is the fox news rundown
[Music]
friday september 11th 2020
i'm lisa brady an annual tribute to the
thousands of lives lost on 9 11
was almost cancelled by coronavirus
instead
it's expanding we're going to do the
lights in the
in the pentagon and in shanksville so
we're going to be shining those lights
and two other locations that never had
them before
i'm jillian turner is america any safer
from terrorism
19 years after 9 11. it's important for
us not to be complacent and understand
that there are many out there in the
world who seek to do us harm
and i'm guy benson i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
for anyone who lived through it or the
millions who watched the escalating
horror unfold on tv
it's hard to believe 19 years have
passed
since september 11 2001. two airplanes
have crashed into the world trade center
in an apparent terrorist attack on our
country the al-qaeda terror attacks that
killed nearly 3
000 people when 19 hijackers used
passenger planes
as missiles beginning in new
the building on the york end
that's on purpose then they crashed
another plane into the pentagon
many in the building felt a thud and
heard kind of a muffled explosion
and a fourth plane possibly heading for
the nation's capital
crashed into a field in shanksville
pennsylvania as passengers fought back
by the time it was all over less than
two hours after the first plane hit
new york's twin towers had fallen
leaving blocks of debris
covered in toxic dust in giant pieces of
the tower's metal shell
still smoldering three days later when
president george w
bush visited what became known as ground
zero
cheered on by rescue crews and first
responders i can hear you
the rest of the world hears you and the
people
and the people who knock these buildings
down
will hear all of us soon
the deadliest single terror attack in
human history
and the worst ever on u.s soil united
the nation
in an outpouring of grief anger and
patriotism
and emotional memorials have followed
around the country every year
since led by ceremonies at the crash
sites
christian adams donald
leroy adams families reading the victims
names a big part of it in all three
locations
and my cousin ferdinand v marone
superintendent of the port authority
police
who ran in to save others making the
ultimate sacrifice but it won't be quite
the same this year in new york with
pandemic precautions in mind
the 911 memorial and museum plans to
play a recording of the names being read
instead of having loved ones do it live
they also briefly canceled the annual
tribute and light
twin beams shining miles into the air
from near where the towers once stood
that's back on after new york's governor
agreed to provide health personnel to
alleviate safety concerns
but by then a non-profit group was
already planning its own memorial
for the first time yes because in years
past
we didn't have to because the 911
memorial
and the museum their obligation their
first responsibility is to make sure
that 911 is kept sacred
and that we honor all those who perished
you know in this case 19 years ago
frank siller lost his firefighter
brother on 9 11
he's chairman and ceo of the tunnel to
towers foundation
which builds homes for wounded veterans
and the families of fallen service
members and first responders
they didn't do it this year they decided
to just play
recording and i'm sure they whitewashed
it they probably don't have any emotion
in it no
uh no nobody's comments and
um and it's just doesn't give a family
an opportunity a 911 family remembering
opportunities
to you know read their loved ones names
out loud and
and to say hey mom i just graduated
college or i just had my first baby or
or dad you know you know i just i just
became a firefighter or
you know you know you know whatever the
situation is they don't have that
opportunity to talk
and let people know what happened 19
years ago it's got to be kept
you know it's important that we keep
this day
that we read these names out loud in
person on this day every year
and we're going to make sure that the
tunnels the towers foundation so if
they ever drop the ball again we're
going to make sure we pick it up in the
future
um and do that and you know they also
decided not to do the
tower and lights i either the tribute
and lights
and um you know we were doing that until
two days later they found the safe way
of doing it which has always been their
um excuse to not read the names or not
even to do the
the tribute lights was it wasn't safe
because of covert 19 and i said come on
you got to be kidding me we could figure
out a very safe way of doing it we did
in
a matter of days we figured out a very
safe way of doing it
because uh our most important thing is
that we make sure we never forget
and we won't let that happen ever
right and then they as you say they
decided well we can do the tribute in
light but
then their reading of the names portion
was going to be a recording and so and
so you're you're picking that up and
doing it on your own
can you explain though i just want to
focus on the tribute and light for a
minute
can you explain to people 19 years later
why the tribute and light portion means
so much
because it's iconic it is
it is a symbol of what happened that day
when you look at those beautiful lights
blue lights
shining in the skyline of new york city
you remember that those twin towers went
down with so many people
in it 2 97 lives were lost 19 years ago
and we can't keep that day sacred
and and that we honor those who perish
that day there's something wrong with
america
and uh so so you know you look at it and
everyone looks at those lights and say
oh my goodness yeah you know
they remember where they were what
happened they tell their kids about 911
uh once again because it's iconic and
i'd like to add one thing too that
we had the lights we were doing it um
instead we're going to do the lights in
the in the pentagon
and in shanksville so we're going to be
shining those lights and two other
locations that never had them before
uh which we're so honored that we'll
make sure that
these two locations are are not
forgotten and and remembered so
we're proud so out of that ridiculous
decision that the 911 memorial made
we we are going to now do something
that's so beautiful by having the lights
not only in new york city but in in the
pentagon
and in shanksville for the 9 11 museum
ceremony
family members are still invited to
attend but the museum says given the
health risks associated with large
gatherings
an enormous amount of thought went into
how to hold this year's event
safely and that they're committed to a
commemoration as beautiful and
meaningful as ever
while also protecting the well-being of
families the recordings being used for
the names
are part of the museum's in-memorium
exhibition
with the number of lives lost to covet
19 in the u.s
now approaching 200 000 i also wondered
about the ongoing challenge as time
passes of
putting 911 in perspective for future
generations
and what siller hopes is learned from it
well
so that is such a great question because
they don't really teach
what they should be teaching uh enough
about 9 11
in in school so our mission is is the
first mission of tunnel to towers
foundation is to never forget and honor
the sacrifice
we build houses all over the country for
catastrophically injured service members
mortgage-free smart homes
we pay off mortgages for former first
responders we leave young families
left behind that are killed and shot and
especially these police officers uh
recently and and gold star families also
someone gives their life for their
country and leaves a young family behind
we're gonna pay off their mortgage or
build them a mortgage-free home
we do all that we're so proud that you
know that we're proactive in that we see
you could see the results of what my
brother did and so many people did from
9 11 because he inspired his
his family but our first responsibility
is make sure that we never forget
because if you forget you know history
things are going to happen again
and you know are they still trying to
kill us yes you better believe it if if
we didn't wipe out isis and and and and
and go in and take care of different
caliphates you know it's
it's they would come back here if we let
our guards down we're not going to do
that because
we uh we try to make sure that i know we
make sure that we never forget and we
got to make sure america doesn't
especially with the next generation uh
coming up that's you know 19 years ago
you know somebody's
just off to college they have no idea
you know
what happened and uh but it's our
responsibility to make sure they do know
what happened and
so that's why we do the things that we
do this is
very personal for you after the loss of
your brother hero
fighter fighter gave his life trying to
help others on 9 11
and he was off duty at the time how far
has the foundation come how is
your mission going i know the american
people are generous people
but you know on the whole how how is it
going for the foundation
well we we're so proud of the work we're
doing and never in the million years
that we think that our foundation was
going to grow to what we're doing now i
mean we're off
55 homes that we did last year alone 55
mortgage-free homes last year
we're on pace for the same this year and
the 20th anniversary i'm sure we're
gonna
we're gonna our goal is to do a hundred
mortgage free homes
um so covert 19 you speak of it before
you know because it is difficult times i
mean
so much loss of life and it's mostly our
elderly and those who have underlying
health
problems you know two at least two
co-morbidities
um uh we as at the tunnel the towers
foundation we delivered over three
million
ppe personal protective equipment
all over not just the tri-state area in
new york area we're doing washington
we were in chicago we were in detroit we
were in atlanta
we were in florida we we had we
delivered stuff
all over the united states because we
knew that it's a serious uh
it's a serious problem here or some of
our hospitals were overwhelmed most
certainly in the beginning
but we found a very safe way so we
understand
the the urgency and the need to make
sure you take this seriously
but we found a very safe way to make
sure that we can read these names
out loud like i said in person and it
just makes a world of difference for us
it's it's easy to have two different
podiums only send one person up to each
podium and keep them
six feet away and uh and then clean them
off
in between the speakers and it's almost
not that quite that simple because we
have to stage them
away as they come up to the stage you
did mention that you've
you know kind of expanding the mission
during the pandemic
providing ppe and in some cases i know
temporarily covering mortgage payments
for
for frontline healthcare workers too so
what happens
if someone donates to tunnel to towers
right now does it all go into one pot do
they get a choice
of which front line families they want
to support
how's that working yeah you can you can
decide to help us with fallen first
responders or catastrophically injured
service members or covert 19.
there are there are different ways that
you can go to our website and just but
we ask everyone
to donate eleven dollars a month most
americans can do that
eleven dollars a month we had a million
americans
donating eleven dollars a month we could
take care of every police officer every
firefighter every gold star family and
every catastrophically injured service
member
that give their lives for the country or
their body their limbs for their country
that leave young kids behind every year
every single year we could help every
one of them if we had a million people
donating 11
a month i don't think that's hard to do
we're well we're on our way to
to doing that uh we've had great uh
support
and uh people see where their money goes
the great thing about our foundation is
that people see a house getting paid
offer a house being built
you know that's where your 11 goes when
you hear about a police officer that was
just like killed in st
louis uh last last weekend um
and we paid that mortgage off he had
three young kids under the age of 10
um people see where their money goes and
it's a good feeling that you know
i don't take a salary my family doesn't
take a salary we have a
this year will be 94 cents of every
dollar goes to our programs
uh very few foundations can say these
words that
you know that what we do and and make
sure that the money goes to those who
who really need it so once again 11 a
month can really
i say the goodness of america you know
you know america
is great it's good but the goodness of
america the generosity of america has to
take care of the greatness of america
and who is the greatness those are
willing to die
for you and me and that is the police
officers firefighters and our military
we better take care of them and we are
and we will
tunnel the towers foundation for sure
frank ziller chairman and ceo of tunnel
to towers
thanks so much for all you do thank you
god bless
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
usually during a presidential election
season foreign policy and national
security
takes a back seat to domestic issues
like employment and the economy
this year's no exception so far the
coronavirus pandemic is sucking up
most of the campaign trail oxygen as it
should
with nearly 190 thousand americans
killed
but there was considerable talk about
isis being defeated during the rnc
recently with multiple officials touting
the defeat of isis as one of president
trump's
signature first term achievements today
because of the president's determination
and leadership
the isis caliphate is wiped out it's
gone it's evil leader
abu bakr al-baghdadi is dead and our
brave soldiers
they're on their way home joe biden is
good for iran and isis
great for communist china and he's a
godsend to everyone who wants america to
apologize
abstain and abandon our values
donald trump takes a different approach
he's tough on china
and he took on isis and one president
trump
demolished the terrorist isis caliphate
in the middle east
and eliminated its leader al baghdadi
one of the world's most brutal
terrorists today is also september 11th
it's been 19 years since al qaeda
executed
the largest terror attack on u.s soil in
history
prompting president george w bush to
launch the war on terror
and coming up in october it's going to
be one year since the trump
administration took out isis leader abu
bakr al-baghdadi
so now is a good moment to get a
temperature check and ask
are we safer today than we were four
years ago
i think that the loss of baghdadi hurts
them
dan hoffman is a fox news contributor
and former cia station chief
it certainly hurts their ability to
recruit followers and let's remember too
that one of the lessons from 911 is the
last thing you want to do is give
our terrorist adversaries ungoverned
space from which
to plot attacks against us and so
destroying that was was critical for us
there's no sign that abu bakr
al-baghdadi's successor is anything
of the sort of demagogue that baghdadi
was but make no mistake isis has a lot
of those
mid-level terrorist leaders who are
still
hell-bent on targeting us worldwide so
that's interesting because
last election cycle go around back in
2016. it seemed like
isis still posed sort of potentially you
know an
existential threat to the u.s everybody
was talking about it both candidates
trump and clinton all the time
this time around because baghdadi's gone
you say we've got these kind of
mid-level guys
running the operation so should
americans still
be concerned about terrorism should they
factor in this election cycle the
candidate's ability
to do things like protect the homeland
and americans abroad
from terrorists is this something they
should be thinking about when they go to
the polls are we kind of in the clear
yeah i don't think we're in the clear i
do believe look if you asked americans
who abu bakr al-baghdadi is i think a
great majority of us would know
the name but his replacement abu ibrahim
al-quraishi probably a teeny tiny
percentage of our population is is even
aware
of him and so i think there is a
tendency for us
perhaps to become a little bit
complacent we've got other things to
worry about like the coronavirus and
economic crisis
and civil rights issues in this country
and mass
populist you know protests but it
doesn't mean that the terrorist threat
has
has gone away and uh you know i think
that one of the things we've seen is
that
the economic hardship and the
coronavirus combined has provided
the terrorist leaders with an
opportunity to recruit followers and do
so more effectively
so you brought me to my next question
which is really
a lot of the world detention has been
focused on
combating the coronavirus and the
economic fallout in various countries
here in the u.s we've been hit
particularly hard on both fronts right
in terms of
the virus numbers infecting americans
and in terms of the economic fallout
do you think though their
terrorist leaders are making inroads and
trying to take advantage of
the lack of attention on them does this
give them
an advantage that they may not have had
six months ago
well i think certainly there's the
potential for our own
you know homegrown disaffected a
population to be more susceptible to
being recruited
potentially by terrorists and and we
know that that's
a risk that that we take and it's
something that the fbi focuses on
to a great extent but i would too
highlight i mean the trump
administration has
has had some some significant successes
that have really put
some of these terrorist groups on their
heels um they've wiped out the
leadership in
al-qaeda and the arabian peninsula in
fact um
killing uh ibrahim al-assiri
in a drone strike in late 2017 michael
morell former acting director cia said
that was the most significant
um targeting operation since taking down
bin laden so that was a big deal but
this is in the news because we're the
president is talking about removing
our troops from afghanistan and iraq um
and the question i think that our voters
need to think about is well is that
going that forward presence is that
there's some value to that
um in terms of uh detecting and
preempting threats before they're
visited on
on our shores or not and that's that's
something i think i'd like to hear from
both candidates about their own their
calculus about that
so for our listeners who aren't as
familiar with some of these groups as
you might be as none of us
really are so you mentioned aqap which
is
shorthand for al qaeda in the arabian
peninsula
al-qaeda in yemen that's a really strong
offshoot
of al-qaeda you mentioned president
trump has actually had a pretty major
success with with that so that's good
news right the fact that you know maybe
while isis is still out there al qaeda's
on the wane at least
it's most powerful arm yeah i mean the
al-qaeda
peninsula the the leader kasim already
the trump administration
uh targeted him he was the emir of aqap
targeted uh just january of this year
and killed
uh and that was the the offshoot of al
qaeda that at least
we used to assess was the most potent
the greatest threat
to the homeland but al qaeda is going to
to grow
in these failed states and um
until those states are no longer failed
states they're still
they're gonna find it you know like a
petri dish they're gonna grow
which is why i've always felt like we
need to be out there in some
form or fashion diplomats military
intelligence some forward deployed
presence uh
out there on the front lines if we look
at
the biden record because we're trying to
talk 2020 here as well
on counter terrorism he's biden's really
best
known publicly anyway for his role
planning the operation
that killed osama bin laden while he was
vice president this was back in 2011.
the sort of conventional wisdom the
story out there is that he was one of
the few if not the only voice in the
situation room that really
urged president obama not to authorize
the capture and kill of bin laden at the
time so this has really come to define
his legacy and record on
counterterrorism
is that fair and then my next question
to you
is is it that black and white i mean you
just for our listeners you were there
you were in the room at cia
when these decisions were being made in
real time
so tell us if you think it's fair to
judge biden on that one decision
i was in the room when a lot of those
discussions were having
were taking place about bin laden and we
were
looking at the intelligence and trying
to determine
as well as we could whether bin laden
was actually there or not there and
we didn't see him so we couldn't prove
with any degree of certainty that he
really was there
um we used to take polls in the in the
you know in the meetings with our senior
people and ask him okay
how strongly do you feel he's actually
there is it 50
60 percent um and i'll tell you there
were some hard
counterterrorism you know cia officers
who have been doing this their whole
lives
who were at 50 and some of them even
said no we're not ready to do this yet
we need to collect more intelligence
what director panetta believed was that
we had kind of run out of time and the
concern was that bin laden was going to
be moving
from that location and panetta felt like
we'd reached a tipping point
vice president biden had his view he was
i think justifiably concerned about
putting our seal team members at risk
and flying into pakistan without telling
the pakistanis
that we were doing that um with you know
a kinetic operation on their territory
there were huge risks there i think from
a political standpoint
you know president obama looked at that
and thought you know if it's a 50 50
chance that he's there
how am i going to explain this to my
constituents that i didn't act
and i think frankly being there i can
tell you i think that had an
impact on him but the intelligence
wasn't certain and it's a classic case
of making a
a very important decision without
perfect information
i don't fault vice president biden for
having those views
what i will say that's interesting about
him that's somewhat similar to president
trump and i'd like to hear them both
comment on this
after we killed bin laden vice president
biden believed we should have just
we were done we needed to retain maybe a
very small counterterrorism force but
leave
the region and a lot of us felt like
even though we killed bin laden there
was still more work to be done and and i
wouldn't say that i necessarily agreed
with the vice president at the time
dan a final thought from you here
when you look back to four years ago
the 2016 campaign cycle and where we
were
in september of that year before
president trump was elected in november
do you feel that when it comes to the
war on terror america
has made progress do you feel like
americans are safer today than they were
then
i definitely think we're a lot safer
um i think there's a lot of there's some
a lot there's a lot of good reasons for
that certainly
destroying the the physical caliphate
the isis caliphate
which the obama administration began in
the trump administration
ended it and they also gave our military
uh the wherewithal to to do what they
needed to do
in a far more expansive capacity than
obama administration
did i think destroying the al-qaeda
leadership and the isis leadership also
makes us
safer at the same time
it's important for us not to be
complacent and understand that there are
many
out there in the world who seek to do us
harm not just state actors like iran and
north korea not to mention china or
russia
but disaffected um
terrorists who seek uh to target us
worldwide
and that's the essence of why we have
these brave
uh patriots who you know for them the
all that matters the only mission that
matters is is keeping us safe here in
the homeland
that that's how they measure success and
i think on 9 11 as we
remember the fallen we also have to
i think be thankful for all of those
and and look it's a teeny tiny small
percentage of our population out there
on the front lines protecting us this is
not world war ii
or vietnam we've got teeny tiny numbers
of troops
and and and intelligence officers and
diplomats and intelligence community
writ large
and it's a time to remember them and be
thankful for for what they're doing
dan hoffman thanks so much always great
hearing from you
hearing your perspective and learning
from you we really appreciate it
it's my pleasure it's always a pleasure
and an honor
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to the untold story
with martha mccallum the host of the
story on fox news channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold story subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a dna test has turned a new york man
from an only child to the eldest of
three brothers
mel adler's daughter took a 23andme dna
test which
changed his life my daughter called me
and said hey
you know you're not going to believe to
sit down you've got you know i found an
uncle
mel had been adopted as a baby and
didn't know he had two younger
biological brothers
todd neeson and randy bartlian nissan
and bartlian had grown up together in
wisconsin
raised by their mother elaine who had
put male up for adoption
years before they were born their father
died when they were children
elaine passed away in 2016 never telling
them about their older brother from the
same father
bartlian says the new family dynamic
does change things a little one of the
most shocking things about this whole
discovery was that i was no longer the
oldest child
neeson says he's excited to get to know
his new sibling
i'm just really excited and it's it's
this is going to be a cool next chapter
in our in all of our lives
and he thinks their parents would be
happy they found each other assuming
she's where i think she is
and she has a better view of the world
and
everything like that she's probably
smiling yeah i think so that's why
and i'm pretty certain our father's
smiling too this week the brothers
finally met
at the tampa airport at fox 13 tampa
bay's cameras were rolling
one mississippi two mississippi
are you all right the three brothers
later told bay news 9 that they plan to
spend the whole week catching up
first with a fishing trip then a golf
outing and finally a trip to the
shooting range
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy benson
what's on your mind months ago the
democrat-controlled house of
representatives passed a round
four coveted relief bill it was widely
derided even by the liberal media
as unserious and a wish list of
left-wing
irrelevant policies since then
washington has been at a standstill when
it comes to needed coronavirus relief
with negotiations going nowhere
senate republicans put together a
package that targeted some of the most
urgent priorities and it garnered
majority support in the upper chamber
but democrats using the filibuster
a tool they're talking about getting rid
of if they win back control in november
blocked the legislative process from
even moving forward every single senate
democrat
voted to filibuster covet 19 relief
despite the acute needs of
millions of americans their calculation
is that they'll get away with it because
the press is on their side and this will
remain a live
issue for them to exploit and blame the
president it's up to voters to decide
whether or not they pay any price
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes